Alibaba is making its largest overseas investment with a one-billion-dollar deal...
...for control of a Singapore-based e-commerce company.
Alibaba will pay $500 million for new shares in the Lazada Group...
...and purchase an equal amount from existing investors.
The Lazada deal adds sales of clothing and electronics...
...in six Southeast Asian markets.
Billionaire Alibaba Chairman Jack Ma...
...has set a goal of getting at least half the company’s revenue from overseas.
While Alibaba has come to dominate e-commerce in its home market,...
...it remains dependent on China for the most of its business.
Venture capital expert Saemin Ahn...
...says the deal marks a significant departure for Alibaba,...
...which has mainly chosen to grow organically on its home turf.